[Applaudissements]
sans coeur
c'est le nombre de personnes sans
domicile en france aujourd'hui
ils ont cinq six ans à toulouse une
véritable urgence sociale
moi je m'appelle julien et avec l'équipe
jean titude on a décidé d'agir pour
venir en aide à ces personnes qui
parlent dans le truc c'est un projet qui
a commencé il ya trois ans ici même à
l'exacte dose et on s'est dit que si
l'état en visuel on arrivait bien
approuvé une partie de la solution
même si on n'était pas les immigrés en
libye c'est vraiment de glace nos
compétences au service de quelque chose
tu t'y à la société un petit peu plus
utile calculer le nombre de bières qui
vous fallait retenir toute la soirée sur
notre canapé qui était notre activité
principale
ce qu'on fait toujours aujourd'hui et
donc voilà on a décidé de réfléchir
comment aider ces personnes sont sans
abri et en parallèle on s'est aperçu que
partout quand ils vous envoyer de
grandes affiches qui visait du rôle du
roi entre aix et baptiste est totalement
vide
un cerveau de cette société capitaliste
qui produit pour produire pour alimenter
la croissance mais sans réelle
destination derrière et au final se
demander est ce que ce n'est pas ça la
solution hébergée les personnes sans
abri dans ces espaces laissés vides
ça paraissait assez évident donc on sic
que c'était forcément existait alors la
chercher sur google et on n'a pas trouvé
grand chose et ça nous a vraiment motivé
à essayer
creusez sujet donc on a commencé à
travailler sur notre temps libre est en
fait voilà maintenant comment on fait
pour transformer un bâtiment de bureaux
en hébergement pour personnes sans
domicile
or l'idée c'était de regret et comment
des lieux de vie où les personnes
puissent se sentir chez dell est chez
soi on a peint une chambre une cuisine
une salle denon est donc tout ce qu'ils
valent et qu'on arrive à recréer ces
pièces à l'intérêt avait des open space
par exemple et en plus on avait quelques
contraintes il fallait qu on puisse
rendre le bâtiment dans l'état
propriétaire ne varie pas faire de
travaux il fallait également que notre
solution elle soit démontable pouvoir
être utilisé tant que l'invention d'un
bâtiment puis un autre puis sur un autre
afin d'avoir une solution durable et
durera pas votre cas ça veut aussi dire
modulable adaptable à la fois aux
personnes au public qu'on va héberger et
aux bâtiments qu'on va utiliser parce
que le contexte sera toujours différents
et puis il fallait évidemment que ça pue
pas cher pour être au pays des droits de
l'homme quand il s'agit de d'offrir un
point ce qui le rend pas on sera quand
même très rapidement à de vraies
contraintes économiques et donc on a
travaillé sur cette solution technique
et au bout d'une grosse année de
prototypage on a réussi à créer des
modules
du coup fall du sanitaire et les modules
cuisine qui répondait à ce cahier des
charges
en fait le concept c'était un peu la
boîte dans la boîte
donc voilà deux parfaits on avait un
emploi et vergers du texas à la bombe
évidemment pas aussi simple que ça il
fallait avoir le droit d'héberger des
personnes en dépression de bureau ça en
fait c'était juste créé nous allons
consacrer un petit peu de temps et en
plus de ça il fallait que les personnes
quand les belges sur des durées qui
reste assez courtes ça soit pour l
enlever tremplin vers le logement
personnel et la réinsertion sociale on
travaille donc toujours en partenariat
avec des associations des deux logements
qui vont accompagner ces personnes tout
au long de leur hébergement et donc ça
nous a demandé de réunir autour d'une
même table les promoteurs immobiliers
les pouvoirs publics et les associations
des de l'otan démontre que parfois tout
oppose mais c'était là aussi l'intérêt
du projet c'était dernier vers les
réunir dans un but commun et on ya mis
beaucoup d'énergie et enfin cette année
on a réussi nos premières opérations
d'hébergement
on a eu peur j'ai 22 personnes cet hiver
à toulouse en héberge encore 5 à paris
sur un bâtiment nous a mis à disposition
pour les trois prochaines années
on a enfin réussi à concrétiser ce
projet et ça lui a vraiment donné tout
son sens et ça nous a aussi montré que
cet exercice est gratifiant ressort
vraiment pas pareil ces journées de
travail
quand on sait que le soir grâce à nous
et à l'est par sa couleur rose à thouars
alors que la veille elle était d'ordre
est donc le nom des start-ups ce projet
il va emmener d'autres parce que l'enjeu
et fiscales et dans 500 personnes qui
meurent chaque année dans bruch et on
est une quinzaine de bénévoles chimie
dit tu vas travailler à ce projet et à
le développer à continuer ce combat ou
en fait l'objectif c'est de mettre
l'urbanisme transitoire au service ville
plus inclusive du solidaire c'est à dire
que si pendant d occupation temporaire
on arrive à créer les espaces qui
permettent
l'entrée de social de recréer du lien
social c'est dans 500 ans présent et est
ce projet nous a aussi donné à nous
questionner sur la ville de demain aussi
la société dans laquelle on vit
et surtout la société qu'on a envie de
créer et je vous apprends blé en disant
que les enjeux ils sont multiples et
surtout qu'ils sont tous y est on peut
difficilement essayer de se battre pour
une société plus juste et pas prendre en
compte son impact sur la planète sur les
ressources et même sens que
difficilement assez vous prenez une
société plus durable plus respectueuse
de l'environnement s'en prendre à
rétablir un minimum de justice sociale
et donc on s'est pas mal questionner là
dessus et ça nous a aussi amené une
question plus personnelle c'est quelle
est notre place dans tout ça c'est notre
rôle nous qui est pour la plupart dans
l'équipe j'ai passé cinq années ici à
monza dans plus de devenir ingénieur
qu'est-ce que qu'est ce qu'on peut faire
dans cette société et on pense vraiment
que nous a donnée arrête tes clés pour
comprendre les enjeux
qui régissent un peu la société qui nous
entoure et surtout quand on nous a donné
cette possibilité de choisir la
direction dans laquelle on a envie
d'aller
et c'est ça le plus important se rendre
compte qu'on peut choisir et j'aurais
même envie de dire qu'on doit le choisir
d'aller dans la direction qui nous anime
notamment parce que je pense que le
système actuel nous a même droit dans un
bureau ovale aurait pu perdre est sans
ressources et les injustices sociales et
non pour faire simple est ce que leur
envie de vous transmettre l'envié du
haut de mes 6 mois d'expérience dans le
monde du travail c'est que l'as la chose
que ça m'a vraiment appris de travail et
j'ai dit qu un projet qui nous plaît au
public les phobiques motivé pour les
drailles c'est que mettre ses
compétences au service de ses valeurs
c'est à la fois le meilleur moyen de
s'épanouir
et agir pour un monde meilleur
perso
[Applaudissements]